yes Rupa Huck who is actually a front
Venture was speaking at a fringe meeting
now during that uh Fringe meeting she
said a very controversially about
quasi-coating superficially he is a
black man he went to Eaton I think he
went to a very expensive prep school all
the way if you hear him on the Today
program you wouldn't know he's black
well that prompted outrage from Jake
Barry who is the new conservative party
chairman and he demanded action from
Sakia starmer well in the last few
minutes that action has now come and the
labor leadership spokes person for Sakia
has said that Sakia condemns those
remarks and he has urged her to withdraw
them and to apologize and she has been
what they call administratively
suspended she's lost the wet whip
temporarily most people here think it
was a stupid remark to make a very
offensive and insensitive remark and
there is real Fury amongst the uh the
labor High command that on a day when
um the leader has made what has widely
been regarded here as a successful
speech uh that uh this uh this uh remark
has come from well what uh labor MPS
here would say someone who ought to know
better so a a very insensitive insulting
if you like remark by Rupa Huck about
quasi quateng protests from the Tories
and she's now lost the whip temporarily
whilst an investigation is carried out
but uh the the labor leadership's acted
pretty swiftly here because it's only
happened a few hours ago and uh when we
spoke to the shadow foreign secretary
recently he gave us a an idea of just
how Furious the top levels of the party
are about this remark
extraordinary things to say look about a
fellow politician even though you're on
different I do think that the vast
majority of the public are hugely
concerned at this trickle-down economics
the run on the pounding these are basic
racist comments as a consequence of that
so let us focus on the mainstream let us
focus on jobs let us focus on climate
let us focus on growth and prosperity we
have been talking about that though for
the whole conference I'm sorry I make no
apologies this is not the moment to
discuss I don't apologize for racist
comments this is the moment to focus on
care starmer and what he's just
delivered for the country
well that's David Lammy talking to our
colleague Liz Bates a short time ago
clearly uh Furious that this has grabbed
attention diverted attention from the
leader's speech but since that interview
she has indeed been suspended and uh
we'll wait to see what further action is
taken about Rupa Huck but uh anger and
real Fury at the top of the labor party
at the remarks made by Rupa Huck about
the chancellor uh quasiquating